here are five differences between the
mortal engines book and film
fans love Phillip reads sci-fi quartet
two books which have been adapted to
screen by Peter Jackson but did you
notice these five alterations one
fans have commented that heroine Hester
Shah has a dramatically reduced scar in
the film the character you recognized in
the books looks a little different on
the screen okay mr. scar is a digital
scar we did have a mass silicone
prosthetic that was designed which we
shot her through the whole film but it
just it just was wasn't tactful enough
and doesn't have the actual depth that
we need and the only way you can get
that because with a prosthetic you know
you can only actually build up the only
way to actually even to the skin is to
cut them or to actually use a immovable
collodion which was used extensively and
in the old days is really bad for your
skin see I like to use it and it was
used in Tom Berenger important it
actually shrinks your skin he painted on
so he couldn't do that not era to st.
Paul's Cathedral the book features giant
traction cities one of which was based
on London there's no one traction city
can look like the other yeah and they
all just have to be believable in their
own world so Eversole target and it's a
mining town expecting something that
should look like it town expects on the
design of st. paul's was changed d we
flip st. paul's around it's a bit of
teaser trailer st. paul's actually the
orientation of the doors facing forward
it's it's this thing in the book where
there's a statue of one of the gods
clear and clear was always reaching back
into the past
so she's facing backwards and so we
wanted london to have this it's it's
moving forward but then everything is
sort of more facing the back the wind
tunnel effect three minions
in the books Disney characters are
prayed to in the futuristic London
Museum but as the film is produced by
Universal these have been changed to
minions for Shrike the characterization
of stalker Shrike is one of the best
things about the film actor Stephen Lang
who you might recognize from Avatar
bought some unusual influences to the
role to make him look a little different
shrikes described in the book he's got
you know quite big proportions and he's
a bit bit more robotic and we just
worked that worked out the more human we
made as proportions he felt more
sympathetic Stephen sort of looked at
sort of different birds because the
Shrike bird is actually the butcher bird
he's sort of looking at some stuff that
Rudolf Nureyev did for Swan Lake and now
you've moved like a bird and not move as
arms would be very easy for him to feel
Terminator escort have some kind of
locomotion that made him feel slightly
awkward and so gave him the grace v Anna
Fang G hey Kim stars as Anna Fang in the
movie you might know her as a badass
character in the books but they have
really stepped it up in the movie I
think being such a strong empowered
character with such complexities there
it was a gift because he gifted me
actually help me get empowered myself
to become leader of the anti traction
League she worked with mark Trotter he
was a nine times world champion of
Taekwondo fans will be pleased to her
true name is revealed in the film Anna
Fang has another name which we managed
to get that reference in there and and
and sort of a little bit of an
explanation about where it came from
tell us in the comments below if you
spotted anything that we didn't
you